nearly 10 million people have downloaded
germany's new coronavirus tracing app
in just three days there's still a ways
to go
scientists say that 60 of the public
needs to use the app
for it to be effective and the
government says that buy-in
is critical the app can help the app can
help to warn contacts of infected
persons faster than was previously
possible
and every hour of early warning of a
threat of infection
is a gain in fighting this virus
but as governments around the world
track the virus can we be sure
they also aren't tracking citizens
tracing apps can we trust them are they
effective
and this is dw's coveted 19 special i'm
steven beardsley berlin
it's good to have you with us can a
surge of new tracing apps help stop the
viruses spread
we'll hear from an expert in just a
moment but first let's look at some of
those apps
and how they differ here in china as the
coronavirus spread
the government set out to fight it with
the help of a smartphone app
launched in february the aliplay health
code app was the first attempt to slow
the transmission rate of covet 19
by tracking infected people digitally
using information from their smartphones
the app analyzes personal data to assign
a color code that either grants users
access to
or bars them from buses trains and
public spaces
south korea launched its own contact
tracing program shortly after china
requiring all international visitors to
download a tracing app at the airport
but the country's effort to monitor the
virus doesn't rely
on this app alone the south korean
health authority also tracks infected
people
using surveillance cameras and credit
card information
singapore led the way in creating an app
that can monitor the spread of the virus
without government surveillance
the country's app traced together uses
encrypted and anonymized data to alert
those who have come in contact with
infected people
australia has launched its own app based
on the trace together protocol
in europe france italy and germany
launched coronavirus tracing apps this
month
prioritizing privacy the italian and
german apps use a decentralized approach
they don't store user's information on a
server but rather on the user's phones
the french stop covid app however is
centralized
it does store data on government-run
servers but says the data is deleted
after 14 days
the uk is preparing to launch an app
similar to the french model
later this month the european commission
has called for a common tracing
technology across the eu
but so far member countries have been
going it alone
let's take a closer look at france now
they released its app at the beginning
of this month
and as mentioned in that report it
relies on centralized data storage
and that is giving pause to some
potential users
michelle downloaded stop kovid as soon
as it was launched
users who test positive get a barcode
they can
enter in the app stop kavid then alerts
other users who they've been in close
contact with
sam
the app is on a voluntary basis and
obviously doesn't replace
other measures like face masks
but it's one out of several tools that
can help protect me and the people i
meet
michelle hasn't tested positive nor has
she received an alert
there are no official figures on how
many alerts have been sent out so
far but she still hopes the app will be
effective
i know that there have been epidemics in
the past but i never thought i'd live to
experience one
it was frightening and very worrying and
it's too early to say if it's over
we need to keep up our guard
but only about two percent of people in
france have downloaded the app so far
many are concerned the government might
use stop kovid
to track people but michelle says that
doesn't bother her
we are all using mobile phones and being
tracked through relay masts
it's very easy to know where people have
been at a certain point in time
also through facebook and twitter
compared to that stop kaveed
is not a threat michelle hopes more
people will use the app
and that the covet 19 epidemic soon
becomes a thing of the past
i'm joined now by ralph yanz he's the
founder of research to guidance
that's consulting firm for the digital
health industry in berlin
ralph it's good to have you with us
first of all now the german app came out
this week and it already has 10 million
downloads
does that make it a success
no it's definitely a very good start
also compared to
other official tracing apps
in other of other countries so
they have performed uh much worse
uh than uh here in germany so it's a
good start but
let's see how that further develops
we think that maybe um first movers have
now downloaded
it yeah and now becomes a hard part of
the game
to convince all the other ones the other
ones who are
a bit skeptical here to also download
and install this application but it's a
good start anyhow
now this app works without a centralized
data registry
should that reassure users about their
data security
yeah it's definitely a much secure in
terms of privacy
approach so yes uh
i mean the balancing of brighter data
privacy
and being able to fight
the pandemic with the help of a tracing
app we think
that the balance is being has been
reached and
we would recommend downloading the
application
as we heard earlier there are plenty of
other national apps france italy
um singapore for example how effective
is it going to be when people are
traveling across borders and they have
their own countries app but maybe not in
other countries
yeah that's right i mean that's still a
problem and
so if you met somebody who's affected in
another country
and he's using a different app then your
app wouldn't
wouldn't know about it yeah so still
our country apps are still not talking
to each other
that might take a while until those
solutions are going to be interoperable
but for now they can't talk to each
other are we seeing any efforts to
create a unified app for example maybe
in the eu
yeah i mean there at the very beginning
there have been
discussions on the european level to
come up with one approach which works
[Music]
uh in all the countries but then it
turned out
that country interests were so different
so that
each of the countries they decided to go
first their
own way maybe when
there will be a second wave or the
pandemic takes
longer then they will meet again and
then find ways there to
to merge and to let those applications
talk to each other
but not for now now we've been talking
about tracing apps this whole time but
there are other digital
tools that can be used in this pandemic
what can you give us an example of yeah
sure i mean
there are plenty and the tracing
phase is just a very very tiny
phase within the overall spectrum of
what
is what is available out there so
i mean there are hundreds of solutions
out there which help to educate the
users
about their risk of getting effective or
of being affected
there are lots of triage solutions out
there which help
patients or users have to find the next
testing stations
and and also
make appointments here with doctors here
to do the test
then we have the tracking and tracing
phase of this whole pandemic management
and
then we come to current time management
and during current time management there
are also
lots of tools which have been made
available during the pandemic
in a very very quick way which allows
the patients had to manage their
basically their their health status with
while being current timed either
self-imposed
or enforced so there are lots of
solutions already out there today
all right ralph janz of research to
guidance a digital health consulting
firm thank you very much
thank you and it's time now to answer
your questions about kova 19
over to our science correspondent derek
williams
does high altitude affect the
transmission of covet 19
interestingly yes it seems to
when when i went looking for information
on this i found
a recent study comparing infection rates
in
low-lying parts of china and bolivia
to mountainous areas and it showed that
the higher you go
the fewer cases of covet 19 you find
um now a lot of that's probably down to
environmental factors of course like
like
higher uv radiation at altitude and
more drastic temperature swings and
drier
air which could all play a role in
hindering um virus replication
but the researchers also postulated that
that a physiological factor could be
playing a role
people who live in low oxygen
environments
at high altitudes have way fewer
ace2 receptors in their heart and lung
cells it's it's
an adjustment the body makes to to thin
air
and since those are the receptors the
virus uses to invade your body
having a lot less of them in those
organs might protect you
can you give us a status update on
possible vaccines for covid19
the who is is keeping a running count of
the
steadily mounting number of vaccine
candidates in the pipeline there are
are over 140 of them out there now of
of those most are still in what's called
the
the pre-clinical stage so in cell
culture
or in animal testing but but 13
have moved on to clinical evaluation
which means
they're being checked for for safety and
efficacy
in humans only one has reached phase
three which is the last stage of the
process
before approval by the way the speed at
which this is going
is really pretty jaw dropping and for
for a vaccine candidate reaching phase 3
after less than six months is unheard of
the virus reportedly killed the
president of burundi in about four days
is that common burundi is one of the few
countries
worldwide to to not impose any
restrictions during the pandemic
and that was largely due to its
president pierre and currenziza
he died in early june from from what the
country's government said
was a heart attack after suddenly
growing ill but
but it still hasn't been confirmed that
he had coveted 19.
um if the disease was in some way
directly responsible for his death then
the very
short time it took to kill him would
indeed be
anomalous the most recent study i found
puts the average period between the
first
symptoms and the death of someone who
succumbs to the disease
at between 17 and 18 days
but but because blood clots are of
course
one symptom of covet 19 i guess that
could could theoretically cause
a sudden crisis like like a heart attack
at an earlier stage as well